[Music]
foreign
how do the dragons from Game of Thrones
and House of the Dragon breathe fire do
they have specific fire glands what is
the source of their fire questions we
will answer here in this video let's get
to it
to understand this we should first know
how the dragons were created it is
stated that dragons are believed to be
intrinsically tied and bound to Magic in
the world of A Song of Ice and Fire
there were quite a few theories as to
their Origins for example it was
believed that they were originally from
the shadowlands of ashai or that they
came from a broken moon were the most
accepted origin story was that there
were dragon eggs discovered by the
valyrians in the land of the 14 fires
and with blood rituals and Fire magic
they bound their bloodlines to the
dragons and hence people like the
targaryens or their offsprings were the
only ones capable of bonding with a
dragon
so now that we know their body structure
let's take a look into the first real
question how do they breathe fire well
the most obvious answer is through their
mouths but we are going to be going for
a more in-depth explanation so the
theory goes that since they have immense
air sacs or flight bladders that either
produce or store in a lighter than air
gas it would be safe to infer that the
gas would most probably be flammable and
the source of their fire the air sacs
would then have tubes that connect with
excretory units as seen in the mouths of
these dragons that look like fire glands
every dragon in House of the dragon and
even in Game of Thrones have these two
holes on the size of their mouths and
these are the fire glands
so the only probable gases that are
lighter than air and flammable are
methane and hydrogen which means that
either one of these or a fantasy element
is produced inside these air sacs and
they become the biological source of a
dragon's fire but this is a magical
world and the dragons are intrinsically
attached to Magic therefore the ignition
of the gas would also be done by
intrinsic magic and maybe the gas that
was produced in the air sacs are also
elements that are only found in that
world these spots would most obviously
be created in the mouth of the dragon as
seen when Danny's dragons tried spewing
out fire For the First Time as babies
now that the basic process of how
dragonfly is created is understood the
next question is how long can we breathe
fire
there should always be a limitation but
since these creatures are born of magic
then I bet it's their life force that is
tied to the world that also continuously
creates the gas which is ignited and
turned into dragonflame we can see a
near unlimited volume of flame when
Danny's dragons were fighting the dead
when they were burning the ships in
Marine when drogon was born in King's
Landing and carax is fighting the crap
people in the stepstones the amount of
gas and fire would have far exceeded the
ability of the best compressed natural
gas cylinders in the world today
therefore meaning that a dragon's fire
is near unlimited only held back by the
dragon stamina and his life force
so how hot is the flame of a dragon well
the temperature of dragon fire
correlates with the size of the specific
Dragon which means that bigger the
dragon hotter the flame valerian's fire
had a temperature of more than 2000
degrees Celsius which was hot enough to
melt the granite and stone walls of
harrenhal as was stated in the books we
have seen Vega spew out fire to burn
Lena valerion to a crisp but a human
body is as easy a task as can be garaxis
was able to turn the crab people into
Ash inside their armor which means the
temperature would have been easily over
one thousand to 1200 degrees Celsius but
drogon even though smaller than Valerian
was able to melt the Iron Throne made of
numerous steel swords therefore this
would put his fire temperature to around
the same as valerion around 1800 to 2000
degrees Celsius that's hot the living
viserion had the same flame maybe
similar to drogons but the undead dragon
under the 9 King's control had a very
blue flame now we might think that the
blue fire is hotter than yellow or red
fire as is still to us in elementary
school but this flame is quite the
opposite it's a gold blue gold magic
plasma that is empowered by the white
Walker's magic this magic even increases
the stamina of the undead dragon so that
he can spew out the flame near
continuously even coming out of the
holes inside his body without actually
burning the body of the undead base
therefore this fire is quite the
opposite to drogon's Red Flames it is a
cold magical fire that can destroy true
intense coal and brute foes
so that's about it for Dragonfire from
House of the dragon and Game of Thrones
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel till
the next one take care fam